was das fit ist fit ich würde sich aber
ich bin sicher ich krieg schaden liege
bei generations aerospace und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge team
oder kids das erste mal seit langem und
wie immer funktioniert das so ich werde
jetzt rennrunden spielen hier vorne in
der warteschlange und ich werde euch die
besten zusammenschneiden das beste kippt
gibt es zuging ende es wird nicht das
allerletzte sein aber es wird so gegen
ende kommen also alles wie immer ich
würde sagen wir starten jetzt mal direkt
rein ich wünsche euch viel spaß bringen
uns eine neue sache es gibt hier ist ein
sogenanntes kit rating scheinbar kann
man da festlegen dass man dann nur die
guten kids bekommen sonst so leute dann
lass uns doch direkt mal startet man vom
in der ganz klassischen pvp rhone wir
haben hier einmal die abos protection
zwei helm protection zwei auch aus
diamant wir haben eine heimischen zwei
linien postens einen golden apple und
hier oben eine an breaking drei wurden
ex und ich würde sagen
hier begeben und marlen den namen baut
den pilz ab vielleicht kann er dann von
da oben eine harry potter werfen
es ist ein kalkül dunkel einer
raffiniert war weggelaufen mir dann die
haben glaube ich dass dies ein fehler
war an
ja er kriegt noch paar hits solo an
immerhin aber durch melamin gegeben tut
mir dann mein herz belegen jetzt habe
ich gewonnen habe kann ich dann sicher
besser einsetzen als er sagt so jetzt
kommt zack zack zack links rechts oben
unten krieg noch eine unterfeld an
darunter und stirbt unfallschaden alter
bitter
das hier ist übrigens das
bewertungssystem sicher dass also man
kann von 1 super mäßig schlecht und
spielbar hier bewerten
juhu ich hab grad eben einfach die ganze
zeit fünf eingestellt weil ich dachte
dass wir das beste oder 1er westen aber
fünf es einfach eines der schlechtesten
aber hier keine kitzeln bewerten kann
man auch weg machen scheinbar dass es
gut zu wissen und dem kit geben wir
jetzt mal das war nicht gut auch okay
was hp event geht genau solche kids
wollt ich leute ich hab die ganze zeit
ebenso darauf gewartet ihr einfach ein
basketballkorb okay und hier haben wir
einfach schien
was passiert wenn jetzt einfach hier so
rändern hin pflanze kann ich entschieden
funktion ein
jetzt können wir irgendwie man kann den
wilders baumann kann auch ein hotspot
okay ich baue man horst erster schritt
dann versuchen wir das zu zähmen kommen
ja komm lass mich zehn ja wirklich ein
ja würde mich ja der gekommen und ziehen
wir aus dann machen wir etwas mit den
logos mal gucken immer so vallori würden
diese loren die nennt man doch loriot
oder jetzt liebt er mich du liebst mich
jetzt kommt lieb mich doch kommt schon
lieb mich doch jetzt lebt er mich jetzt
liegt habe ich auf jeden fall fürs auch
gleich kommt das nein nein ich habe ein
halbes herz dahin warte warte ist ein
objekt drauf ja das noch drauf hier viel
spaß und es ist krieg der basketball
oder wie ich habe ja schon mal eine
folge krüger fußball gemacht dass jetzt
über basketball glaube ich kommt walter
nein zu dem was man macht jetzt eine
breitseite
ich bin gestorben
das kind war auf jeden fall super und es
geht direkt weiter direkt mit dem
nächsten spider kit witches kann man's
porno aufpassen
und hier ist die pausen porschen die
isst du erstmal okay mit auf die og zeit
nämlich seine mitstreiter erst mal nein
nein
walter ist die olympia meister im
weitwurf hatte ich es hin wie weit ihr
geworfen hat
geben lass mir aus ich bin nicht mehr
geteilt aber lulic ist ok der switch
lasst mich hier hoch alter diesen
überall com bekämen zudem trüben oder
ist immer noch geäußert ich sagte komm
ich sage wenn ich noch sagt erster
instanz
beschluss gab verstaubt meint ich mein
halbes herzalter was das war einfach ein
gutes gilt für gamer fakt ist dass als
allererstes muss ich mal sagen die maps
haben sich deutlich verbessert hier auf
dem monja lesen wunderschön guck mal
hier so ein labyrinth
nein kein labyrinth eigentlich so eine
kleine allee und jetzt kommt manchmal
das kit hier an dieser star heißt
einfach larissa dort exe rotter fakt ist
mein gegner
das war etwas was macht was sollte da
was macht ihr da was das machte ich wie
hat er das gemacht auffallen blog auf
android
ich verstehe es nicht es bot das ja okay
okay ist gespannt hören das war nicht
1.9 oder html wer ist er dazu sprung
doppeljob drin nach so ja okay der box
und jetzt also kriegst direkt ein und
bog in die fresse acquire kommt zu mir
es gibt jetzt was ins gesicht für dich
es gibt jetzt einen fairen communicator
von hier von zack zack zack kommt eine
kuh die karte auch noch warm junge ja
ohnehin die wand geklatscht kommt
springt einfach nicht so springt er
nicht benutzt aber sein double job nicht
so
dann stirbt gerade hatte ich schon die
hoffen wir das neue system verloren da
guckt mal das ja an
wir haben hier einfach eine portion of
leaping eine ender perle und einen
schwamm aber sie sind irgendwann der
schwarm heißt spongebob nicht dass ich
jetzt über die maßen feiern würde aber
er hat einfach schamlos 5 und dafür muss
man die pops geben dem spongebob 15 hat
jetzt wirklich nicht jeder schwamm vor
nicht der spongebob und ich würd sagen
mit graphen ist ein fachmann oder was
ist mit dem ich habe liebling porschen
nein wir müssen sie jetzt gut wir müssen
es schlau spielen irgendwie schlau
und so geht auch einige tage dauern ja
sehr schön
was das angeht ist für kidd ich würde
sich bahr ich bin sich beim krieg
schaden generation
ich habe water missions die nichts
machen und sie heissen clg g6 and what
the [ __ ] was ist das ich will gerne
schlagen kommt stirbt vielleicht kann
ich ein schaden machen
es ist das wild card alter mann ist
alles auf diesen basketball court alter
macht keinen sinn kommt nein darf nicht
sterben
nein nein stimmt mich stück für stück
nicht du musst sterben mit wie ich meine
du du du bist an
nein nein die porsche teams hälfte
schätzt du stirbst kommt kann man
sterben in diesem kit kann die box
sterben ja man kann sterben
er hatte auch ein halbes jahr so wie ich
die ganze zeit ist jetzt unser freund
mit diesen loris und den kritikern und
diesmal mache ich es dir nicht soweit
bitte bring ich dich um
nein trinke ich nicht direkt und wir
können spaß haben hier mit power bogen
nein nein geh weg weg ich habe hier ein
klima für dich du kannst kein krieg
hinter dir vielleicht wieder wischt sehr
geil sein körper und tempo einfach noch
immer was zu sagen war kann man was
machen die mit dass minecraft and i mit
der irgendwie war ich wurde obwohl es
über die luft jagen aber das kernproblem
ist einfach so ich weiß nicht wie man
das mal kräftig entgegen der lobby der
hochlagen kann ihr könnt ja mal die
kommentare schreiben
er sagt warte wasserschlosses krieg aber
was optimal screen ja klar komme machen
und ich hab noch gewonnen hoffentlich
hat er noch einen screen machen können
alter aber hat er glaube ich das
hinbekommen aber als das war's von
heutigen folge leute wenn euch die
gefallen hat dann lass gerne daumen nach
oben da schreibt in die kommentare wie
man das am besten spielen soll jetzt mit
diesem neuen update wälder ideen habt
wie man da die lustigsten kids kommt
schreibt gerne und reinigt diesmal alle
kommentare natürlich wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder haut rein macht's
gut